hey everyone today we're going to talk
about the times the loud house went way
too far with their bad behavior
inappropriate jokes and weird moments
watch until the end to find out which
completely inappropriate r-rated movie
was quoted in one of their episodes who
wants to watch robot destroyer Wiener
jokes the loud house has never been
known to shy away from a good wiener
joke and this particular moment is no
different in the episode titled and
ticked off Lincoln quickly begins to
feel like a third wheel Ben Clyde and
Zach bond over a shared interest in
shopping for antiques feeling super
bummed out Lincoln goes home to be alone
when he discovers an email about his
favorite magician he finds out that they
amazing Braille stir is giving a
top-secret show that day the email says
to bring a friend
but since Lincoln thinks that Clyde will
be too busy searching for antique
treasures with Zach he invites other
friends instead the first call he makes
is to his country bumpkin pal Liam Liam
is milking a cow when he takes the call
Lincoln invites him to the show but Liam
declines he says he would love to but
that it's Wiener season on the farm he
goes on to explain that this is the
magical time of the year when they wean
piglets from the mothers and then he
says he needs to be around in case
there's some kind of wine scene I need
to be around in case there's some kind
of wind scene for example okay okay I
get it
we think it's safe to say they took that
joke a little too far total destruction
and chaos it's no secret that the loud
kids are all about destruction and chaos
we can't even count the number of times
they've destroyed their house that's
kind of the whole point of the show
learning to live and love each other
amidst all the craziness but after these
examples you might agree that they are
taking the whole destruction element out
of proportion in the episode release
invents lie-detector glasses they allow
me to track micro-expressions pulse
pupil dilation and perspiration to
determine on truth there's a scene where
Linda senior opens the bathroom door to
find the most disgusting
we've ever seen in the bathroom
seriously this tops the worst porta
potty in the country and no guts no
glory
the loud kids completely destroy their
entire house when their parents go out
on a date
baby Laurie in charge which is a total
bummer for the rest of the siblings
because she won't let them do anything
they want to do they call her the queen
of know and devise a plan to overthrow
her and put Lincoln in charge they
ambush her and tie her to a chair this
isn't exactly role model behavior to
display for children then the kids
totally destroyed the house they also
wrecked the house in the episode it's a
loud loud loud loud house inappropriate
behavior and bizarre paranoia if there's
one thing the loud house is chock-full
of it's bizarre and inappropriate
behavior with a side of good
old-fashioned paranoia like an antiqued
off when Clyde is asking Zach to come to
the flea market with him to shop for
antiques Zach says something random and
strange he says that his parents only
decorate with transparent items because
you never know where those government
spies put their listening devices you
never know where those government spies
put their listening devices okay that's
a weird and totally paranoid thing to
say then there's a part where Lincoln
Clyde and Zach are in the library
showing off their antique treasures Zach
drags a rug into the room and that's
Clyde over with it then he accidentally
hits Lincoln with it too he jokes that
he is glad he didn't get a sword dark
humor alert not to mention all the times
they ransacked her own house seriously
who fills up their own house with dirt
for dirt bike racing Lincoln seems like
the team is sibling of the bunch oh this
guy wants to do is read comic books and
play video games while his sisters are
practically blowing up the house dirty
jokes and toilet humor when it comes to
the loud house dirty jokes are aplenty
you just have to be mature enough to
appreciate them for instance in the
episode space invaders Lynne comments
about Lincoln's room saying that she is
noticing a complete lack of balls Lynne
pauses and Lincoln gets an uncomfortable
look on his face then
Lyne covers up that dirty joke by
bringing in a pillowcase full of sports
balls
according to movies insights in the UK
version of this episode they removed
Lynn's paws and Lincoln's uncomfortable
expression you know I'm noticing a
complete lack of balls in this room no
soccer balls no footballs no baseball's
no boss why because they knew to show
with too far with that joke and if that
joke wasn't too much for you there's
plenty of potty humor to go around you
all probably remember the Frog butt from
the episode where Lin loud senior opened
his own restaurant then there's his
classy comments made and in turn for the
worst Lin's teammate Margo asks Lin to
hold her hotdogs because she's got to
take a wicked dump can you hold my dog
linsanity I gotta take a wicked dump now
we're pretty sure the show's creators
don't want kids repeating that line then
Lin doubles down on this toilet joke
when she tells her that she cannot go
number two until the team is number one
no that's gross more dirty jokes there
are so many inappropriate jokes in the
show we couldn't pick just five so here
are some more times the loud house went
too far with crude and dirty humor in
Locke and loud Lisa reveals that she's a
creepy peeper
she accidentally shares that she has had
cameras in the bathroom for a full year
why is the bathroom the safe room
because of the cameras I installed last
year um why was she watching her
siblings while they were on the toilet
and taking showers you installed cameras
no that's super creepy then as if that's
not weird enough
she later asks Lennie and Laurie for a
stool sample I also need a stool sample
for your security system yuck Lisa
sometimes the show will allude to an
inappropriate scene from another movie
as they did in serial offender Linda
zooming down the aisle of the grocery
store on a shopping cart when she yells
yippee ki-yay market shoppers you'll
only get this reference if you've seen
the movie die hard which is a totally
inappropriate movie for kids
the film Bruce Willis says a famous line
that starts with yippee ki-yay but he
doesn't say market shoppers after that
he says something that most of us
wouldn't dare repeat let's just say they
are referring to a quote that kids
should not be hearing and we thought
this was a cartoon for a young audiences
which allowed house moment do you think
went too far let us know in the comments
thanks for watching the things if you
like the loud house as much as we do
subscribe to our channel and give this
video a big thumbs up catch you later
[Music]